today's video is brought to you by
athletic greens and its wonderful
daily blend of vitamins and minerals ag-1
by athletic greens is a comprehensive
all-in-one greens powder engineered to
fill the nutritional gaps in your diet
and support your body's nutritional
needs across four pillars of health
gut health immune support energy and recovery
it's packed with 75 vitamins and minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients combining the
perfect amount of micronutrients absorption and
taste to jumpstart your daily routine you'll be
hard-pressed to find a more comprehensive powder
supplement on the market right now look as you
guys know i'm not exactly a fitness youtuber but
i do like to eat right take care of myself
an ag-1 is that comprehensive nutritional
supplement that i know is going to account for
any holes that i might have in my diet just
one scoop into the water bottle in the morning
shake it all up take a hit off it easy does it
and you know you're good for the day either
with my coffee in the morning i feel it kind of
sustains my energy a little bit not sure if that's
just placebo or uh either way it's all rather good
for you isn't it plus age one is gluten free dairy
free paleo vegan keto low allergen and low calorie
less than one gram of sugar per serving look
it's the perfect dietary support regimen so if
this sounds like the supplement that you've been
looking for then grab your own immunity bottle
that's one year of vitamin d hold on looks like
this little dropper that you add to it plus five
of these individual travel packs so if you go away
for the weekend boom just grab a couple of those
and you can keep up with your routine brilliant
these are all for free by the way with your first
purchase go to athleticgreens.com forward slash
biographics again year split vitamin d the travel
packs at athletic greens dot com forward slash
biographics link below and now today's video
in 1976 a nightmare afflicted central africa from
the depths of the lush humid forests an invisible
killer struck out for civilization carried by
animals it passed like a ghost into humans who
took it with them back to their families but this
was no evil spirits no creature of folklore no
it was something much worse the ebola virus twin
outbreaks that year were humanity's first contact
with one of the world's most terrifying
diseases hundreds died in agonized misery
wracked by fevers in some cases bleeding from
every orifice but while these villagers were
the first known humans to die of ebola they
certainly would not be the last in the decades
since that poisonous summer ebola has reared
its ugly head again and again modern-day drc
south sudan gabon uganda nigeria guinea sierra
leone liberia and more have all been afflicted
with the worst epidemic in 2014 killing 11
000 people yet even as scores succumbed to
this plague humanity was mounting a fight back
that would eventually lead to a breakthrough
a tale of both horror and hope this is the
story of ebola the disease of nightmares
of all the ways mother nature wants you dead
perhaps no method is quite as terrifying as
ebola one of three known phyla viruses it belongs
to the same family as the similarly icky albeit
less deadly marburg virus like marburg its natural
home is the dense forest of central africa where
it's thought to circulate widely among bats and
just like marburg catching it will put you on a
non-stop express ride to a very yucky hell at
some point between 2 and 21 days after you've
been exposed you'll be hit with a sudden feeling
of illness one that seems to come out of nowhere
at first this will be merely unpleasant you'll
suffer sore throat fever joint pain headache
and a general feeling of weakness unless you've
previously been in contact with an ebola patient
you'll probably assume you're suffering from a
nasty bout of flu well hold on to that feeling
because when the full force of ebola really hits
you'll find yourself praying for the good old
days of influenza not long after your faux flu
symptoms develop a wave of vomiting and diarrhea
will overcome you but this is still just the
beginning deep inside your body the real horrors
of the virus will be starting to reveal themselves
ebola you see affects the way your blood clots
this leads to something called disseminated
intravascular coagulation of antiwar saying
that it makes your goddamn blood vessels leak and
since all that blood has to go somewhere we get to
ebola's freakiest stage when blood starts seeping
out of your orifices now this symptom doesn't
affect every victim but it happens often enough
that it seared itself on popular memory with good
reason the worst afflicted suffer blood coming
from their mouths ears eyes noses and rectums
add to this rash and hiccups and you'll spend
your last hours on earth as a horrific mess before
finally dying of multiple organ failure and make
no mistake dying is almost certainly what you'll
do right now there are four known subtypes of
ebola that affect humans plus two resin and
membali that only sicken on human primates the
four that you have to worry about one type thai
forest has only ever infected a single person a
researcher who caught it while examining a dead
chimpanzee the other three though are where things
get really freaky whether you catch the zanya
sudan or buddha bug yod subtypes the highest
survival rate you can expect is a mere 60 and
this is the best case scenario catch zaire ebola
virus and there's a 90 chance of death it's simply
one of the deadliest viruses known to man luckily
though the chances of you ever being exposed to
this killer are unbelievably remote while viruses
like flu and covered 19 spread on tiny droplets
produced by coughing or sneezing ebola doesn't
work that way nor can you catch it by shaking
hands with or sitting near an asymptomatic person
the most common way to pick up the virus is by
coming into contact with bodily fluids a serious
problem for healthcare workers but less so for
say youtubers yay other routes of transmission
include sharing dirty needles touching soiled
clothing or traditional funerary rites that
involve contact with the body oh and you can
also catch it by having unprotected sex with the
guy who recovered from ebola for some gross reason
virus remains in men's semen for ages still these
relatively difficult routes of transmission mean
ebola rarely crops up outside of remote villages
and since it's a disease of the forest most
epidemics can be traced back to forest workers
who come into contact with infected animals or
to people who eat contaminated bush meat and
even if you catch it it's mostly treatable
since 2020 the fda has licensed two types
of ebola medicine for the zaire subtitle
cutting the mortality rate by 90 percent yet it
wasn't always this way just a handful of years
ago ebola wasn't just a terrifying virus when
it first emerged it was also a death sentence
most scientists today are pretty sure that ebola
existed long before the first documented cases
circulating among wild animals in the congo's
impenetrable forests and there it might have
stayed had population growth not led to people
slowly encroaching on those same rainforests
the first known human case was a cotton
factory storekeeper in what is now south sudan
tiny place known as nazara on june 27th 1976 the
man came down with an unknown illness dying a mere
five days later in no time at all the contagion
was sweeping the factory felling his co-workers
before spreading to a nearby hospital thought to
have been caused by bats roosting in the factory
the outbreak eventually infected 284 people
killing 151 but while this is the earliest
known ebola outbreak on record it wasn't the
one that gave the virus its name that honor
would go to a near simultaneous epidemic
some 700 kilometers away in yambuku zaire
now the democratic republic of the congo that
september local teacher mabala laquila fell ill
and died with virus early similar to the one that
had killed so many in sudan that summer for those
living in laquila's tight-knit missionary
community his death and its hideous nature
were a source of shock but that shock quickly
mutated into sheer terror over the coming days the
local hospital was flooded with patients people
paralyzed with pain people bleeding from their
pores soon 318 people were sick with 280 of them
dying the catholic mission itself was devastated
in small surrounding villages the majority of the
population was wiped out faced with this unknown
threat zaya's dictator placed the entire region
under martial law it was this chaos that led to
the virus being named after a river mabala
laquila had visited before he became ill it
would only be later that scientists discovered the
ebola river had nothing to do with the illness or
why it was spreading so fast no it was the mission
itself that was infecting so many people issued
with only five syringes a day for 300 patients the
local nuns had taken it upon themselves to start
reusing needles needles that now carry the deadly
virus to new victims eventually congolese doctor
jean-jacques mayembe and belgium microbiologist
peter pio managed to figure out what was going
on and halt the spread but not before they'd done
something groundbreaking it was from their samples
that the new virus was isolated the cause of
the nightmare illness was finally identified
the last victim died on november 5th leaving
behind a devastated region yet this wouldn't be
the end of ebola just three years later the virus
resurfaced in nazara in the same cotton factory as
before this time infecting 33 people and killing
22 not that it was the exact same virus that had
killed mabala aquila although it was long assumed
that the nazara and yambuku outbreaks came from
the same source scientists later discovered they
were two distinctive subtypes of ebola zaire and
sudan but whether they were the same or different
they both subsequently vanished yeah they just
vanished totally at least in humans after the
smaller 1979 outbreak there would be no more
documented cases of ebola in humans for 15 years
when it did return in 1994 it would initially be
just a single scientist infected while examining a
dead chimpanzee in ivory coast's thai forest sadly
though this pause would turn out to be exactly
that a pause a chance for the virus to gather its
breath and prepare for the next onslaught because
as you already know ebola did not vanish in 1979
eventually it would come back and
when it did it'd be deadlier than ever
even during its post-1979 pause ebola continued
to weigh heavily on humanity's mind if you're
old enough you might remember the scare around
infected monkeys at a lab in reston virginia
where a new strain of ebola was discovered that
fell primates in eye-watering numbers thankfully
the rest and subtype turned out to cause no
symptoms in the handful of humans it infected a
fact that should go down as one of history's great
near-misses still the scare kept the virus in the
headlines and nor was it the only ebola warrior
in the uk scientist portend down managed to
accidentally prick himself with the contaminated
needle while he survived two scientists who
managed the same screw-up in russia weren't so
lucky both went to die horrible and tragic deaths
still as 1994 dawned it was on a world in which
ebola was just an exotic word one tinged with
fear but still abstract enough to be comfortable
unfortunately for humanity things were about to
get decidedly uncomfortable at the end of 1994
disturbing reports started filtering into the city
of makoko inkabon of primates out in the forests
dying horribly not long after that the first human
patients arrived at the hospital men who'd been
hunting for gold near where the apes had been
found and were now experiencing the tell-tale
symptoms of ebola although its return was a shock
the gabon outbreak was contained rapidly a mere 52
people fell ill with only 31 dying far fewer than
either of the 1976 flare-ups but gabon's brush
with death was only the warm-up act the headline
would be taking place to the south and east in
one of the viruses original homes zaire the 1995
outbreak in the town of kikwit was the resurgence
that virologists had feared after a charcoal maker
came back from the forest feeling ill ebola
exploded across the region multiple hospitals
became clearing houses for the disease in kikwit
and surrounding villages swats of people fell ill
desperate to stop the spread the government
blocked the road to kinshasa by the time the
epidemic was brought under control panic had swept
the world and 254 people were dead and this time
there would be no vast gap between outbreaks
the rest of the 1990s and into the 2000s saw
a kaleidoscope of ebola flare up some big some
small until barely a year could go by without a
bunch of villagers dying horribly as the outbreaks
increased they also spread to new countries like
uganda and the republic of the congo and the
number of infected also started creeping up
the 2000 to 2001 uganda outbreak saw the number of
patients in a single event climb over 400 for the
first time meanwhile yet another variant emerged
this time around the town of bundy bugio taking
the total number of human affecting ebola viruses
up to four by the end of the first decade of the
21st century over a thousand people were known
to have died of ebola a low number compared to
say gobert 19 but high enough to represent
a real worry still this worry did come with
a silver lining even as new records were broken
for infections in a single outbreak the numbers
themselves remain manageable bad as it was for
those of the epicenter even 425 cases in one
go wasn't apocalyptically bad and while ebola
refused to go away there was some hope that we
could learn to live with it after all we thought
we understood it that it was a disease of the
forests and villages that it was scary as heck but
could easily be stopped before it got out of hand
how wrong we were just like all those magazines
in 2016 preparing madam president front covers
humanity in this era had badly misjudged things
come 2014 ebola would go from freaky thing it's
fun to read about on cracked.com to the
bringer of west africa's local apocalypse
by any arctic the death of a mill omono was
a gut-wrenching tragedy just two years old
emil passed away on december 28 2013 in
guinea a country of around 13 million people
on the west african coast many many
kilometers away from congo's tropical forests
sad as this lamil's death was though it was
just a preview of what would soon become
one of the biggest tragedies in the region's
history the boy you see hadn't just died young
he'd died of ebola the first time the
disease claimed a life in west africa
and it certainly wouldn't be the last within weeks
of emil's death half of his family had also died
killed by a virus as swift as it was brutal after
that came the mourners then the healthcare workers
before long the death toll in guinea was creeping
up it would take the authorities until march 2014
to recognize the deaths for what they were part
of a new ebola epidemic one striking a country
that had never experienced it before yet it
wouldn't stop at just guinea by the end of the
month the virus was cropping up in the country's
crowded capital the first time ebola had ever
attacked an urban setting but it would be another
funeral that made the disease start spreading
like blood red wildfire given guinea's fragile
health system many of the viruses victims turned
instead to faith healers the most famous
of whom was sierra leone's mendenhall when
she too died of ebola the funeral was massive
people came from all over guinea sierra leone
and liberia to pay their respects respect that as
tradition dictated involved contact with her body
sadly that was just what the virus needed
mendenhall's funeral was a super spreader
event sending dozens back to their home countries
with ebola already working its dark magic in
their bloodstreams by may both sierra leone and
liberia announced they were fighting outbreaks
with things in sierra leone being particularly
acute the hospital in the country's second city
kanema was soon overrun and with hygiene practices
not being followed ebola soon began to spread
among patients workers and visitors alike as west
africa's death toll swept into the thousands cases
began appearing in nigeria and senegal followed a
few months later by mali by the end of 2014 9 000
west africans have been killed by the rampaging
virus thousands and thousands more than during
even the deadliest previous outbreak and as the
death toll skyrocketed so too did the conspiracy
theories yep apparently pre-covert humanity was
just as awful as its pandemic counterparts and
not believing stupid bull from social media
in guinea for instance a conspiracy theory
that ebola was a smoke screen for white people
to kill west africans led to eight aid workers
being murdered in the cities meanwhile the rumor
that patients were taken into hospitals to have
their organs harvested resulted in people escaping
isolation wards thus further spreading the disease
it was a tidal wave of disinformation a tsunami
of horse droppings that only caused the epidemic
to get ever worse yet it wasn't just confined
to west africa even as the disease consumed
entire towns in guinea an equally deranged form of
panic was taking root thousands of kilometers away
yep it's time we turned our attention to the
global capital of social media freakouts america
in september 2014 thomas eric duncan stepped off
a plane in texas unaware of the blind terror he'd
soon be trailing in his wake duncan you see was
a liberian national and he hadn't stepped off
the plane alone oh no inside him was a stowaway
a member of the file of iris family picked up
in his home country and when he finally began
showing symptoms he'd kick off a health scare
unseen in america since the 2001 anthrax attacks
the media freak out following the hospitalization
and subsequent gruesome death of duncan was off
the charts shortly before british nurse william
booley had likewise unwittingly brought the virus
into britain well around the same time another aid
worker tested positive in spain for a brief period
the news was full of maps and charts showing
ominous red dots in places like texas new york and
britain places where new cases had been confirmed
millions convinced themselves that it would soon
be sweeping across america yet thanks to better
funded health systems and different burial
traditions ebola never took root there there
was no wave in europe beyond the infection of two
nurses carrying the duncan there was no community
transmission in the u.s but that was cold comfort
for west africa as 2015 began the virus continued
to chart its destructive path eventually 28
000 cases would be confirmed yet even as this
catastrophe unfolded another more hopeful tale
was quietly being written the story of how we at
last began to master this awful illness the search
for an ebola vaccine began way back in mid-1980s
fittingly in marburg germany where one of ebola's
cousins had first been detected in humans there
heinz feldman was working on filoviruses when he
learned of an astounding breakthrough over in yale
a scientist named john jack rose had figured out
how to use a kind of livestock virus known as vsv
as a delivery system for vaccines intrigued
feldman began dabbling with vsb himself seeing if
he couldn't get it to carry the ebola glycoprotein
at this stage the work was mostly theoretical yet
it clearly stayed with feldman in the early 2000s
he ran a test whereby he used vsv to infect a
bunch of mice with ebola's glycoprotein before
exposing them and a control group to the virus
itself unlike their unfortunate counterparts the
vsb infected rodents all survived and so began the
long and torturous path towards an ebola vaccine
there was the 2005 study by tom geissberg which
repeated the mice experiments in primates and
again revealed that vsv deliveries seemed to
offer protection and there was the incident in
2009 when a german researcher accidentally pricked
himself with ebola affected needle and was quickly
given the experimental vaccine as a precaution her
survival showed that it was safe to use in humans
but the biggest boost came with the 2014 outbreak
prior to the tragedy in west africa no government
or pharma company had wanted to finance an ebola
vaccine the disease just cropped up too rarely
and infected too few people to make it profitable
but as the world watched the carnage unfolding in
guinea sierra leone and liberia that calculation
changed at the end of 2014 the company merck
finally agreed to run a trial and that was how
teams from medicine science francieres came
to be on the ground in guinea in early 2015
offering the experimental vaccine to anyone who
needed it to be clear by this time the epidemic
was already winding down improved sanitation and a
widespread understanding that traditional burials
were contributing to the viruses spread had
slowed its pace there's no suggesting the vaccine
ended the outbreak what it did do though was
provide solid proof in a real world setting
that the damn thing really worked in july 2015
respected journal the lancet published the study's
findings taking humankind one giant step closer to
a world without ebola but while this was truly an
incredible breakthrough it came too late for many
in west africa as the epidemic receded it left
behind the sort of death toll usually reserved
for a war over 11 000 people had died while
many of the 17 000 survivors were left suffering a
myriad of complications which today we might call
long ebola in short it had been a catastrophe a
humanitarian disaster on a grand and depressing
scale it was also thankfully perhaps the last
major ebola epidemic the world will ever face
with the vaccine now proven to be both safe
and effective the path has been laid for a
rapid response to further outbreaks when the virus
reared its head again just four years later in drc
teams were on the ground armed with shots
within just eight days over a quarter of a
million people were vaccinated and while over 2000
people still died the virus stalled out with far
fewer fatalities than in 2014. nor was the vaccine
the only leap forward in 2019 a similar real-world
study was conducted with experimental treatments
using monoclonal antibodies during an outbreak of
zaire ebola virus astonishingly researchers
showed they raised survival rates to a staggering
90 percent by the end of 2020 the fda had finally
approved two ebola treatments and one vaccine with
a separate vaccine targeting the sudan sub type
already under development in england and that's
where things regarding ebola stand today on
the threshold of perhaps a grey new era one
in which this disease of nightmares will soon
be reduced to a treatable if unpleasant illness
it's a change that can't come soon enough
since it first reared its ugly head in 1976
ebola has been responsible for tens of
thousands of deaths nearly all of them
on the african continent in this it has been
helped by autocratic leaders and corrupt
governments the kind that pour so little money
into health care that overcrowded hospitals
become places that spread the disease rather than
contain it and honestly this might be a bowler's
real tragedy since the late 1970s we've known that
the best way to stop ebola is simple using gloves
isolating patients and giving healthcare workers
proper protective equipment yet thanks to poverty
and neglect it's been able to crop up time
and time again to kill those already living
on the margins the fight humanity has waged
against ebola might be one we're on the verge
of winning but until we tackle the root causes the
factors that drove it to become so deadly in 2014
will sadly remain in place ready and waiting
for the next nightmare virus to arise
so i hope you enjoyed today's video before you
leave let me tell you about a new channel that
i'm doing called into the shadows so maybe the
world isn't dark enough for you well good news it
absolutely is and if you'd like to know more about
the horrible things that humans have been doing to
each other since well time immemorial well please
check out that new channel into the shadows from
land mines to penal colonies to horrific diseases
if it's horrific we cover it check it out through
the link in the description below again it's
called into the shadows and thank you for watching